[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans un entretien
sur france 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
et raphaël grossistes et le directeur
général de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique il est avec nous
depuis le siège de l'agencé onusienne à
vienne merci beaucoup monsieur gros si
[Musique]
on va commencer par l'ukraine il ya eu
plusieurs incidents dans des centrales
nucléaires le 4 mars les forces russes
ont pris le contrôle de zaporijia c'est
la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'europe et ce lundi l'opérateur
ukrainien energoatom a accusé l'armée
russe d'avoir fait exploser des
munitions près d'un réacteur de cette
usine quelles sont les informations dont
vous disposez est ce que vous êtes
inquiet de ces derniers développements
c'est à dire qu'on est en général on est
très inquiet de la situation en général
à l ukraine
pour ce qui concerne la sûreté et la
sécurité de toutes les installations
nucléaires
l'installation des apports india on vous
dit bien c'est un c'est un site qui
contient six réacteurs et où la semaine
dernière déjà on avait eu un épisode
avec des échanges de feu et un feu même
dans une installation
adjointe à un des réacteurs qui a causé
beaucoup d'abord que la quiétude
aujourd'hui il y à une information comme
quoi il y aurait eu un épisode
relativement
mineures mais on n'a pas un appât
confirmation pour l'instant c'est cesser
riant qui
compromettraient la sécurité du réacteur
mais quand même c'est très inquiétant
parce que ça continue à montrer une
incitation à général de violence
je dirais potentiel des violences et des
dangers
qui pourraient à tout moment dé venir
plus important
c'est je dirais la situation des apories
tia et aussi à charm
c'est compliqué car ce sont deux sites
qui est qui sont déjà sous contrôle des
forces armées russes ce n'est pas le cas
des autres sites d autres réacteurs il
ya là 15 en ukraine donc nous suivons ça
de près je dois dire que là mes
consultations avec la la partie
iranienne et le russe évidemment dont on
est en contact avec le 2 donc on a
évoqué et ça et un particulier moi je
dirais dans lé cadre d'une initiative
que j'ai eue de
établir un cadre à gré des spécifiques
haddock des sécurité et de sûreté pour
les installations nucléaires en ukraine
qui est nécessaire parce que à tout
moment comme ces épisodes à répétition
les prouve on pourrait voilà
nous retrouver dans une situation
difficile qu'elle quand on parle de
situation difficile et qu'on parle de
nucléaire monsieur grossi de quoi
va-t-on parler d'un possible accident
nucléaire parce que autant tchernobyl
n'est plus une centrale active autant
apories dia c'est une centrale actif six
réacteurs si on se bat au tour
évidemment on peut arriver à un accident
nucléaire grave
évidemment il ya des principes cardinal
qu'il faut toujours respecter quand il
s'agit d'une installation nucléaire par
commencer par la reine par le respect de
l'intégrité physique d'un réacteur est
aussi
d'autres aspects liés à
l'approvisionnement des
d'électricité dans la centrale les bon
fonctionnement des tout l'appareillage
de sécurité et des sûretés
la situation du personnel
donc il ya une série des piliers je
dirais qu'ils doivent être respectés en
ce moment on boit pas mal des problèmes
pour ce qui est du respect des cds ces
principes
cardinaux comme je disais tout à l'heure
donc
un accident nucléaire ce serait un
événement majeur pour que ça arrive on
devrait se situer peut-être dans
scénario extrême
mais qui n'est pas exclue donc dans la
sécurité nucléaire dans la sûreté
nucléaire il faut pas il faut jamais
laisser que rien livré au hasard donc et
on a vu déjà qu'on a eu deux ou trois
épisodes qui montre la nécessité de
dépasser les niveaux de protection qui
n'est pas suffisant ces moments alors
est ce que ces négociations avec la
partie russe est la partie ukrainienne
avance et sql doivent aussi aboutir de
façon très concrète à des inspections
sur site par des experts de votre agence
et est-ce que vous par exemple est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à vous rendre en
ukraine où est-ce que c'est impossible
comme vous dites bien mais superman moi
j'étais la semaine dernière j'étais
antalya en turquie
où j'aurais trouvé lé ministre lavrov
les ministres coup les bat on s'est
entretenu en a parlé de cette
possibilité moi j'ai manifesté ma
disposition à me rendre sur place
immédiatement
je crois qu'il est important à part les
manifestations de solidarité des
condamnations au des appels à démontrer
l'assistance et le support technique
indispensables sur place donc l'idée
c'est comme je disais tout à l'heure
d'établir un système haddock de sécurité
et aussi de prêter l'assistance et le
support technique y compris y compris
après ma présence et après l'accord sur
un système garantit
des éventuellement avoir de gens de
lagence sur place il n'y a pas des
inspecteurs parce que ont ils seraient
pas là bas en fonction d'inspecteur mais
plus tôt
dans une fonction d'assistance mais
aussi très important de pour nous aider
à bien déterminer la situation sur place
vous avez nous chaque jour on produit un
rapport des situations sur ce qui se
passe dans les installations nucléaires
quelqu'un a dit un jour que dans la
guerre la première victime c'est la
vérité et la réalité c'est que on a des
narrative différentes un côté dit c'est
une catastrophe l'autre dit il ya rien
qui se passe et grâce à nos services
grâce au fait que l' agence ne vienne à
un contact je dirais
institutionnels et permanent avec les
régulateurs nucléaires ukrainiens et les
opérateurs on arrive à déterminer ce qui
ce qui se passe par exemple vous citiez
tout à l'air cet épisode encore une fois
ça pourrait le dire vous verrez dans
quelques minutes ou dans quelques heures
les rapports journaliers del agence va
déterminer exactement ce qui s'est passé
donc pour moi c'est aussi important
d'avoir quelqu'un là-bas sur place afin
dé
déterminer d'une manière objectifs et
sans doute c'est qui ce passe donc
j'espère vraiment de pouvoir y arriver
prévient le président mac ou le podium
accroc lui même a eu l'énorme
gentillesse des intéressés question
importante
on s'est parlé lui-même a par la suite
appelé le président poutine et les
présidents des skis et un plaidant pour
cuivres pour que le il accepte aussi
cette assistance de la jasse donc on est
sonné un plat mieux d'un processus des
négociations et j'espère pouvoir aboutir
mais très vite parce que chaque jour
comme vous venez de voir et complicité
et comme c'est clair départ les
informations à chaque jour est un
épisode il faut éviter que les prochains
soit vraiment grave on va passer
rapidement monsieur grossier un autre
dossier que vous suivez l'iran les
pourparlers vienne ont été suspendus ce
mardi le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères qui recevait son homologue
iranien a affirmé qu on était vraiment
dans la dernière ligne droite pour
trouver un accord et qu'il avait reçu
des garanties écrites de washington que
les sanctions prises contre moscou en
raison de l'ukraine n'affecterait pas
les liens avec l'iran donc une note
d'optimisme
l'eia ne fait pas partie des
négociations mais c'est l'arbitrage ali
dire de la situation à ce que vous êtes
optimiste
est ce que vous êtes optimiste qu'un
accord ait vraiment à portée de main il
faut l'être il faut que cet accord soit
soit conclu moi j'étais personnellement
il ya un peu plus d'une semaine à teyran
où j'ai conclu un accord avec
messi amir abdolahian et les autorités
des lagence iranienne de l'énergie
atomique
pour faciliter ces processus
d'inspection qui est lié à l'accord g6
pillot et donc on a eu ces derniers
jours cette espèce de dx dans les
processus qui jusqu'à jusqu'à la part et
ses avancées très bien et sans problème
est donc là
l'introduction des sanctions et des
limitations économiques et commerciales
évidemment ont posé un problème
inattendu et voilà j'ai j'apprends tout
à l'air comme vous et ses déclarations
domicile à rome attention après je
n'entretiens avec avec messieurs amir
abdolahian et moi j'espère qu'on vous
qu'on puisse commencer à appliquer
l'accord c'est à dire à
avoir le retour si je peux le dire comme
ça un niveau adéquat
de nos inspecteurs nos affections sont
les inspecteurs sont toujours là mais
grâce aux jesse pire et on va on va
avoir j'espère avoir les niveaux de
danse pétition lantin site l'intensité
d'inspectorate qui est absolument
nécessaire vu la dimension du programme
nucléaire iranien donc vous êtes
optimiste vous d'un point de vue
technique et d'un point de vue
diplomatique qu'on est vraiment à la
veille d'un accord avec l'iran on est
prêt il faut il faut pousser on n'est
pas loin on n'est pas loin enfin le gros
si merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux
questions de france 24 et merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien rester sur
nos antennes pour plus d'informations
[Musique]